hey youtubers it's Charlie so awesome
news the flash season 2 just cast
another female speedster
we have Jesse quick that's going to be
joining the cast they also cast a minor
firestorm villain named Tok amok which
is actually the name of a scientific
principle it all off to explain just a
little bit this is more of a Jesse quick
video but they also confirmed that melis
Joe is coming back is Linda part but I
felt like we all knew that she was gonna
come back she's too big of a character
to completely sideline so let's talk
about Jesse quick I'm just gonna do like
a quick rundown of her history in the
comics and talk about the actress that
they cast so the really cool thing is is
that the actors that cast violet bean is
mostly known for doing horror stuff
which I think just sounds really
exciting from a flash perspective I mean
it's not like the flash is gonna go in a
horror direction it's really just a
coincidence what the actors have done
before like they usually they just
audition to them and they cast whoever
is the best actor for a particular role
but the line between comic book villains
and horror villains is just it was
really close and I like the idea that
zoom the the big bad of season 2 is
gonna be more of like a classic horror
villain very big terrifying amazing
spectacle and actually I did find out
that they have not cast zoom yet they
don't have a main actor that's gonna be
playing zoom which pretty much confirms
that it's not going to be like an evil
version of Grant Gustin or an evil
version of Harrison wells the casting
note that I saw it just said that zoom
has not been cast yet it didn't say that
it's not going to be one of the
pre-existing characters but it does
sound like they're gonna find somebody
completely new to come in and fill the
role just put a pin and zoom for a sec
while we talk about Jessie quake will
have to like loop back around when we
get some more zoom info so in the
context of the TV show
Jessie quick is going to be a college
kid that just gonna get caught up in
Barry Allen's fight with zoom they
didn't say if she's coming from earth 1
or 2 they're just there a lot of new
characters coming from earth 2 so it's
totally possible to could go either way
for those that have not read the comics
though Jessie quick is a huge deal
because she's part of the flash family
she's one of the female speedsters at
various points in the comics she's had a
couple different powers in addition to
being super fast she's also been able to
fly her powers flow from the Speed Force
but the way she taps into it is a little
bit different from Barry Allen she
doesn't have the natural connection to
it that Barry does for bear
it's more of like an automatic
biological function Jesse quick is able
to access the Speed Force by using
what's called the speed formula
something that her father helped develop
but the cool thing about her is that
she's part of a multi-generational
superhero family her parents were both
superheroes in the Golden Age
her father was Johnny quick and her
mother was Liberty Bell as the name
implies Johnny quick had SuperSpeed but
he got his powers by reciting a
mathematical formula so that that also
kind of passed on to his daughter but
she actually can visualize the formula
she doesn't have to say it out loud the
way that they explained the formula and
the comics is really funny like the way
that originally started the character
started out in 1941 so naturally a lot
of the explanations behind superhero
origins we're a little sillier back then
but they basically got this super math
formula off of Pharaoh's tomb I guess in
the early 1940s ancient Egypt stories
were really popular who knows whatever
he became a member of the Justice
Society and then later when his daughter
Jesse quick got her powers she also
ended up joining the Justice Society
there was this big run that Geoff Johns
rode on that basically reassembled the
Justice Society looking in the
continuity they had disbanded and then a
couple people got together including Jay
Garrick and put a new team together a
lot of them being the children of
previous Justice Society members I don't
know how they're gonna incorporate the
formula into the TV show or if they're
just gonna give Jesse quick flash powers
the same way everybody else got their
powers via the particle accelerator
explosion they did say that mercury labs
was gonna be a bigger thing in season
two so there might be like some crazy
speed stuff coming out of mercury labs
her mother's powers are equally just as
silly it involves the ringing of the
Liberty Bell the actual Liberty Bell in
Philadelphia when the bell is rung she
gets enhanced speed super strength
stamina sonic vibrations that she admits
is like pulses and she's really good
with hand-to-hand combat so I mean we'll
see what they do with Jesse quick on the
TV show it'll probably a lot more
practical the probably tonot way way
down and the Jesse quick character is
actually just an alias her real name is
Jesse Chambers Jesse quick is the
persona she used when she was acting
more as a speedster later in the comics
she took her mother's mantle of Liberty
Bell and started using that name
I would think just because they're
introducing so many speedsters that
she's definitely going to be Jesse quick
on the TV show so if they give her any
of the powers that she has from the
comics it's pride just gonna be a
SuperSpeed they didn't announce anything
about her parents but her father did own
quickstart enterprises he has like a
large corporation it's kind of like a
mercury labs type situation like a
smaller version of preexisting big
companies like cord industries or Queen
industries or Wayne Enterprises
there was a storyline that she got cut
up when with Wally West when he was
trying to defeat zoom because zoom was
so much more powerful than Wally West
she had to lend Wally some of her powers
some of her Speed Force they haven't
really explored this in season one but
because the Speed Force is a type of
energy it can be transferred between
people so like Wally West can grant
Speed Force to other people like he can
siphon off Speed Force from himself and
give it to other people and he can take
it from other people so now we have five
different flashes that we know about not
including the villain zoom
there's Barry Allen Wally West Jay
Garrick Hot Pursuit who's patty spivot
she had flash powers for a little while
and now Jesse quick so we could see some
of the flashes lending powers to each
other you guys can let me know that like
do you think that will see the different
flashes the good Flash's lending each
other powers to help defeat zoom like
we'll all the other flashes give Barry
their speed so that he can defeat zoom
as cool as that sounds I'd really rather
see all the flashes like the entire
flash family work together to defeat
zoom I don't want it to be like a one on
one thing the thing about zoom that's
different from Professor zoom is that
professor zoom is a genius from the 25th
century zoom was hunter zolomon he's
just a normal guy and yes he is way
faster than Wally West and Barry Allen
but he has a normal level of
intelligence so it stands to reason that
a bunch of geniuses standing around
could figure out a way to defeat them
using what they had if they do go
straight up comic book route though
there will be a lot of transferring of
speed force only instead of everyone
giving Wally West their speed they'll be
giving it to Barry Allen really I think
the opportunity for them on the TV show
in season two is to build out their
supporting cast because there's like a
giant library of amazing characters from
flash comics that they just haven't had
to get to yet and they just they have to
spend time developing those characters
if they want this to be an amazing show
in season seven or season eight or
however long they go if you guys have
never watched Supernatural that's a show
that's made it into season 11 which just
sounds ridiculous TV shows today never
make it that far like if they make it to
four or five seasons that's amazing to
their credit even though they've kept a
really small cast like it's it's a
relatively cheap show to shoot but
they've done an amazing job of
developing side characters like you have
the Castiel character that really didn't
come along to like the middle of the run
I think it was like season four or five
or something like that
now Misha Collins is like part of the
Holy Trinity like it's not just Sam and
Dean anymore so team flash you have
Caitlin Barry and Cisco now you have to
start developing those other characters
like iris West needs some good character
development don't even get me started on
the other flashes like Jay Garrick Wally
West no way that they're going away
after season two they're way too amazing
from a character standpoint to
completely get rid of even Robbie Amell
as firestorm yes he's not supposed to be
part of legends of tomorrow so he's
probably gonna get sidelined by some
comic book storyline for a little while
but generally speaking you know the
first season is all about establishing
the core cast then you slowly start
building the universe out so you guys
can let me know like which side
characters which secondary characters do
you want to get really awesome
storylines this season personally I'd
like to see Caitlin snow get a killer
frost arc it take her a little while to
get there she's not gonna go from zero
to frozen overnight building out Cisco's
vibe character building out wally west
that'll be interesting to meet him I'm
still curious to see how they're gonna
bring him on the show Teddy Sears is Jay
Garrick I really want to see more Linda
Park too because she's so awesome she
was actually more fun for me than iris
West was in season one but that is
because iris was always like the
personal on the outside but the person
who got really upset because nobody told
her what was going on now that that's
over with she can actually have
something fun to do a lot of you guys
have been asking about the trailers
dropping like the big full trailers
usually it's like a minute minute and a
half a little bit longer than that
they'll probably drop next week like
last year around this time it was about
four weeks out when they dropped the
first arrow trailer they'll probably do
the same thing for the flash to why you
guys wait for that you can click here
for a little bit of flash footage just
like a little bit
you can click here to watch my vixen
episode one video thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you